THAT CHAUVIUS SSIVE FORCE AGAI
>>ep THAT'S
ERE HAVE BEE
LI BT
AND FORMPO
S TRIAL, O HAV
S ACCUSED MU
FLOYD.
AYF W OLICE OFFICEE T FORMER PE
SO FAR MNE FORMER POLICE OFFICE
TEIEPROSECUTION.IEF, HAVE
TELEAD INVESTIR
PPREHENSN, AND A
PROSECUTIOPEE USE OF
FROM THE LOS ANGELES
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
CERTAI TE FORCE USED TO A DEGREL
AS SHOWNN EXHIBIT 254, WHETHER
TH BEING APPLIED TFOR TH
YOU HAVE DEFINED WOU CONSTITUTE?
>> WHAT IS THAT OPINION?T IT
SO ASKED
ABD SHOUTING AT
POLICE AS THEY POSSIBLE A
LOUD GROUP TDISTRACT
NDTI
>> YES. D,HT
>> DU BELIEVE THAT OCCURRED?
>> NO, IO NOT.
ODY 1 VIDEO, YOU CAN
HEISS
COMFORT AND PAIN.
U ALSO
TO HIM.
>>AS
PLEA
N'T BREATHE.
>>EL. HE TESTIEOUT
THE MEDICAL COMPCA
OFFICEWHEN PUTTING
PRESSURE ON SOMEONE'BODY.
>> HON DANGERSF TIONAL ASPHYXIA
>> Reporter: SET SAW THE
INTERACTION E HI
ASME WHETHER THE U
FL
ON THE GROUND.
>> THE SEVERITY CRIME
ISSU DHAGE DURING
RAINPERIOD
>> NO, THE CRIME WASHAT
POSSESSIO
WEED HIS EXPERTISE.
USLY TIN ANY COURT OR ST FEDERAO
USE OF FORCE?
>>E NEVER BEEN TRAINED BY
NOT.
>> Reporter: IT WAHATHE CROWD W
CHAUVIN.
LE E YOUR OTHER H
>> Reporter: TRYING TOAKT OF DE
CHAUVIN'ACONGEORGE>> DOEIT SE "O
>> SO IN CHAOSF THE SITUATION, ,
RIGHT?
>>ESHE NEXT POLICE WITNESAMERSO
IN.
teN  THINK HE'S SAYING "I AIN'
LISTENING TO MRSON,
A FORENSIC SCIENCISTOOKING AT
THE FORENSICS.
SHE'BEG ASKEABT SOMEEMS THE DEF
TALKT,
THAT PILL.E CAR WHERE SHE TESTED
WE'RE WAIT TO R MORE OF ONY AS
RESUME IN S HERE.
BY, SARA.
I WANT TO BRIN EIOWILLIAMS AND .
S EXPERT WITE
LOS AN DARTMENT,
TESTIFIED THAT CHAUVIN USE
DEADLY FORCE, AND IN HIS OWNWOE
AND ON THE GROUND.IMPORTANT WASR
THAT FROM AN OUTSIDE EXPERT?
>> RIGHT, LOOK, YOKNOW, THE
A LOT OF T WITNESSES, POLICE
WITNESSES.
I'VE HEARD A 234U7TTER OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO  THEY MIGHT
BE IT, HERING GOING CALLING TOO
WITNESSES.
THE SIMPLE FACIS
RERD I
CRIMINAL TRIALS, YOU HEAR
TERMS ALL THTIME.
IT'S A VERY, VERY HIAR TO
MEET.
PAIAL OF A
POLICE OFFICER, WHERE PUBLIC
ODI AGAINST
CONVICTING PE FIR,CLUDING OUTSI.
NOW, THE DEFENSE ATTACKED HIM,
OR THE FACT THAT HE'S PAIDBUT
NOT AN  ATTORNEYS TO POKE
HOLE T POTENTIAL BIAS.
IMPORTANT FOR THE
PROSECUT HIM GAME QUITLING
CAPTAIN J, THROUGHOUT
THISWEP HEARING T WHON
AT USE OF FORCE.
>> I THINKINS S
DEF
MR. FLOYD. D
FLOYD'S ACTION    S LESSENEDANDE
OO
TESTIMONY.
>> SARA, IS IT CLEAR YET HOW
MUCH MORE WITNESSES THE
PROSECUTION PLANS TO CALL?
DOESN'T JUST
YE KNOW THERE'A ROSTER OPOTENTI.
WE HAVE GONE THROUGH 27, IHINKE
TH
THISE IS A LOU OF FOLKS WHI'ND
WHO SAY ERE'S NOAY THAT
EITHER SIDE  CALL EVERY
WITNESS THAT THEY HAVE
THERE, WHO AREAL
WITNESSES.
SAY THIS ONE THING
ABOU THE TOD.
WE S DIFFERENT
REPORTED, WHICH IS THE JURY. TAG
Y IS.
RY THROUGHOUT THIS, UP L DAY, HH
RIVETED.
THEY DIDN'T TAKE THEIR EYES OFF
THE WITNESS UNLESSHETAKING NOTES
TOY,L PAYINGTENTION, BUT TREHE
BECAUSE THIS HAS NOWE INTO
THE SAME  THEY'RE
INFORMATION OVER ANDR, BUT
EYINLY LOOKED UP WITH
SUE OF WT
SAID THAT CA UP, I WAS
DOING DRUGS OR I'M NOT DOING
WE SHOULD SAY WE LISTEN TO DO A.
Y COULDN'T TELARD TO HEAR.
BEING
>> THAT'S ATNTE'S CLEARLY A LOT
UST WHAT GEORGE
FLOYD EXACTLY SAID.
THE DEFENSE ARGUING THAT HE SAID
I ATE TOO MA DRUGS, BUE SUGGEST
DRUGS.
SO TELL US WHY TS  RELEVANT.
>> THIS IS BACKING UP EXACTLY
WHAT WHA SAID, ANY
CAN LISTEN T VIDEONDSIONHAT HE
SAELL YOU A BRIDGE
INROOKLYN.
WHAT THE DEFENSE IS DOIN
CREATING A QUESTION OF F
THIS WILL PLAY INTO THE CA
DEATH, WAS THEREN HI
R NOT.
CASE, BUT IT'S ONE OF THE
DOUBTS THAT TH PLANT IN
JURORSTH HTO SUFFICIY THROUGH T
ONE JUROR.
NOW, THAT  COM
A  UE
FTER A KNEE
ON HISECAIN SON,R HE
SAID, DIDN'T CHAIN HAVE AN
OBLIGATION TO T
MEDICACA
>> HE DID.
HE  HA NUMBER O
WHVE TALKE